[Music]
all right people
this is the reuben report direct message
and
i have to start with some condemnations
and some things that i need to disavow
we live in a time
where you must disavow things and you
must do it
when other people want you to do it and
you must do it immediately
and then you must do it repeatedly ad
nauseam so i just
i scribbled a few things down and i just
want to get out there i want to get
ahead of things you know what i mean i
want to get ahead
of the news curve and i want to disavow
and condemn a whole bunch of stuff so
please
just bear with me uh for the beginning
here i want to disavow
white supremacy okay i'm disavowing
completely
i want nothing to do with it i also want
to disavow black supremacy
not good don't want to do it i don't
like it okay
i also want to disavow asian supremacy
okay that we're not gonna be doing that
around here okay
that's for sure jewish supremacy no good
sorry jews not gonna do it all right
latino
supremacy also not a good one no mas
okay we're not gonna do that anymore gay
supremacy
sorry no we're not doing it i'm
disavowing completely
trans supremacy no i don't believe in it
and i want to be very specific about
that when i'm talking about decepticon
supremacy so that goes for megatron
starstream soundwave shockwave
the whole thundercracker the whole crew
all right no
no we're not gonna do it i wanted this
about blind supremacy you see a lot of
blind people out there with the stick
and they're poking you
no no no no no uh deaf supremacy
not not gonna do it and i don't know
that are we putting subtitles on this
because that one might slip through the
cracks
i also want to disavow tall supremacy
because you know these tall people
always looking down on everybody
and it's just enough of that and of
course short supremacy because you know
a lot of short people
they're always you know they've got a
little bit of a a little i'm better than
you because i you know sometimes you're
looking straight away you don't see
what's there and then they think you're
better
the one thing that i don't want to
distance myself from and i want to be
very clear about this okay so i've just
denounced
i've disavowed this is what you got to
do it's 20 20.
i want to be very clear that i am in no
way denouncing
um evil alien robot supremacy
because uh i for one welcome our new
overlords when they come because it
can't get crazier
all right people there's a lot of crazy
stuff happening right now
and uh it starts with condemnations and
disavowing so
we're doing uh we're doing three stories
in today's direct message
and uh the first story that we're going
to talk about obviously
is the firestorm over trump either
disavowing or
not disavowing white supremacy depending
on
where you fall politically you saw some
very different things
that happened during the debate the
other night i've already gone into this
i i discussed
that he slightly butchered the answer
that's what i said immediately after the
debate before i saw the media firestorm
uh because he he when he was asked the
question by chris wallace about white
supremacy
because our media is so defunct and d
legitimate and everything else he needed
to repeat the question like a fifth
grader writing an answer on a test
he needed to say i donald j trump
disavow
condemn white supremacy now he's done
this a million times before and we're
going to get to that in just a second
but the way he butchered it when he just
said sure it gives room for the media to
jump in
and of course that's what the media is
doing but i thought what i would show
you
first is uh a clip that is
absolutely catching fire on twitter
right now and i'm glad that it is
uh i tweeted it out it was posted by
somebody before me
but i tweeted out and it's just catching
fire everywhere
this is from a debate in 2016.
that's four years ago and remember now
everyone's saying donald trump refuses
to uh
condemn and disavow white supremacy uh
this is a debate
in 2016 and you're not going to believe
this guess who the moderator of the
debate is
chris wallace and guess what the
question is will you disavow white
supremacy
and let's go to the videotape i totally
disavow
the klud klux klan i totally disavow
david duke i've been doing it now for
two weeks this is you're probably about
the 18th person that's asked me the
question
it was very clear that question was also
talked about in the form of groups
groups i want to know which groups are
you talking about you have to tell me
which groups
ultimately he got to the klutluxland
which obviously i'm going to disavow
and by the way if you look on my twitter
account almost immediately after the
program they were disavowed again
you know it's amazing when i do
something on twitter everybody picks it
up goes all over the place
but when i did this one nobody ever
picks it up take a look at my twitter
account
thank you sir thank you thank you
senator rubin are you willing tonight
to condemn white supremacists and
militia groups
and to say that they need to stand down
and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland are you
prepared to do that
okay so we didn't even need to show you
his response there i showed it to you
the other day you've seen the clip a
million times so that is chris wallace
the same guy asking the same exact
question
four years ago he heard trump's answer
the media has all heard
trump's answer they've heard it
repeatedly but they keep running
with this nonsense so then today at
the white house press briefing press
secretary caleb mcardy
was asked a question by john roberts
about
donald trump further disavowing and
condemning white supremacy
let's take a look let's start off um
i'd like to ask you for a definitive and
declarative statement without ambiguity
or deflection as the person who speaks
for the president
does the president denounce white
supremacism
and groups that espouse it in all their
forms
this has been answered yesterday by the
president himself the day before by the
president himself on the debate stage
the president was asked this he said
sure three times
yesterday he was point blank blank asked
do you
uh denounce white supremacy and he said
i've always denounced any form
of that i can go back and read for you
in august 2019 and one voice our nation
must condemn racism
bigotry and white supremacy in august of
2017.
racism is evil and those who cause
violence in its name are criminals
and thugs including the kkk neo-nazis
white supremacists and other hate groups
i have an entire list of these quotes
that i can go through with you
he is condemned white's privacy more
than any president in modern history
just to clear it up this morning can you
naming it make a declarative statement
that you deny that the president
announces
i just did uh the president has
denounced this repeatedly
the president was asked this you're
making you're contriving a storyline and
a narrative asking you to put it he said
to rest i just did i read you all of the
quotes and if you need to see them in
writing
i will put them in an email paula so
haley
can you right now denounce white
supremacy
white supremacy the kkk and hate groups
in all forms
he signed a resolution to that effect uh
the president just last week perhaps you
all weren't covering it but just
last week expressed his desire to see
the kkk
prosecuted as domestic terrorist this
president
uh had advocated for the death penalty
for a white supremacist the first
federal execution
in 17 years his record on this is
unmistakable and it's shameful that the
media
all right so i think by watching that
unedited clip because i show you
unedited things even though again i'm
not a journalist i wish somebody i wish
we had journalists i'd find something
else to do
um in that unedited clip it's pretty
unambiguous
that the man is condemning the kkk
and has done it in the past david duke
and has done it in the past
white supremacy she even mentions that
he wants to prosecute
uh these groups as domestic terrorists
um she answers the question repeatedly
and clearly now
john uh what john fox
it's not john fox john roberts john fox
he's on fox
uh john roberts i i usually think is a
pretty decent
reporter from what i can tell so i don't
know what he's going for there
um but what they're really trying to do
and and then of course you know these
clips are being spread all over if i
said
kaylee doesn't condem white supremacy
dances around question blah blah she's
literally reading statement after
statement of what the guy has said
over years but you know the media the
media is just dead and the usual
suspects
tweeted out as if he didn't condemn
white supremacy i had to tweet
david frum today because of his nonsense
and then
uh one of these guys this guy aaron
something at fox i try not to make it
about the people
um but it's like you're a journalist at
vox and he tweets out the clip
and again it's the implication no she's
dancing around it she didn't say
he's against white supremacy or anything
like that it's in the freaking clip
this is what gaslighting is and i think
what what trump is realizing and i'm
glad to see so much pushback against it
today um is that gaslighting in effect
is when you
know you've done something and your
opponents
do the complete reverse they do
something so over the top
that you just have to keep dancing for
them while the house burned down around
you
and i think trump fully understands that
this is the way the media plays and has
played for a long time
and i think what he's doing is mapping
a path basically for other people
in this case mostly conservatives or
right-leaning people to
not back down to the nonsense and not
back down to the mob you're seeing the
mob you're
this is when you talk about cancel
culture and the mob and everything else
you're seeing it
in action right now what are all these
people that are telling you that trump
won't denounce
white supremacy and everything else and
i played the clip from charlottesville
the other day where he absolutely
denounces
the neo-nazis and the kkk and even
uh i just tweeted out this morning
bernie sanders has a tweet from
yesterday
where he uses the very fine people on
both sides hoax
now for some reason twitter doesn't put
a oh this is factually untrue
when bernie sanders does it so we know
that there's a that there's a political
leaning and that's a whole
bigger conversation related to big tech
and everything else but what trump is
doing is basically mapping people
and he's showing you know the mob is
going to come for you if you if you say
something that is true and you have a
track record of saying it and everything
else they'll still come for you
never bend the knee so i'm glad to see
so many people have just absolutely had
it and and
the media is burning down their old hat
their own house is this what you guys
want to do
is this what you guys want to do i did
it the other day but here
i'll talk directly to you here i'm going
to do a joe biden joe biden like looking
in the camera and i'm talking to you the
american people
i find it very creepy actually um
i'll talk to you directly jake tapper
and brian stelter
and wolf blitzer and don lemon and
whoever else
guys play the clip of trump and the very
fine hoax thing and show that that
is a hoax show that that's a hoax and
i'll give you credit
gladly give you credit most people will
give you credit the problem is the media
is in the tank so far
for the democrats and they've dug it so
deep
and they never looked back they never
looked back when trump became president
all they had to do was say hey maybe
we did a little something wrong here
maybe we were a little too biased and
people
were voting against it i actually think
what's happening right now
in a weird way it's like yesterday a lot
of people were saying oh you know trump
either lost the debate or certainly
wasn't at his best and the fact that
biden's head didn't explode biden did
okay
i actually think the narrative is
shifting now where it's like they went
in so deep on this nonsense about trump
not disavowing white supremacy
that it's fueling it's fueling the trump
people right now i feel like they're
being a little
a little braver and a little more out
there and and the media is just
completely
losing control and again i know i've
said this a million times so i'll make
it quick
but this is why i did that video the day
after the election sitting in my
backyard we didn't have we didn't even
have a studio
and i did this video saying if you keep
calling him a nazi you're going to
regret it because you're going to paint
yourself into a corner and when it turns
out that he's not a nazi you can't turn
around and say that the nazi ain't that
bad
so this is just an extension of
everything but i i want to say one other
thing about
chris wallace look i don't like
attacking hosts and moderators i know
that as an interviewer you're going to
make some mistakes
you're not going to ask a follow-up
question here someone might be able to
get some misinformation in and you might
miss it
sometimes somebody says so many things
at once that you can only pick one thing
like i'm not going to pretend i'm
perfect i don't think larry king
would pretend that he was perfect i
don't think johnny carson would say that
he was perfect
there's no perfect way of being an
interviewer i don't think barbara
walters would say she was perfect
and there's also no perfect way of being
a moderator
however for chris wallace to ask
virtually the same exact question four
years later
knowing that he knew the answer like if
if he felt if he
really really felt that he had to ask
trump about white supremacy
even though it's not white supremacists
that are burning down buildings you know
west hollywood here
which is the gayest place on earth
they've got a rainbow crosswalk okay all
the gay bars outside
it it couldn't get gay you could put
glitter
in a you put a lot of glitter all over
the place okay and and it wouldn't be
gayer there is a lot of glitter over
there
um the streets are lined with glitter um
it's the gayest place on earth and many
of the buildings are still locked down
and they're locked down the storefronts
are still locked down and they've all
got the signs blm
and we're for peace and justice and
diversity and all this stuff and it's
like
they're not locked down because they
think their windows are going to be
broken by white supremacists
where are the white supremacists running
around breaking windows
and stopping people on the street and
burning down buildings i don't know
where they are could someone point to
where they are
someone could point it please uh let me
know um they're they're
doing it because they're afraid of
antifa they're afraid of blm it's a
protection racket it's basically the
mafia
you put up our sign or we're gonna burn
your store down okay
so everybody's got this whole thing
backwards and i thought that
intersectionality meant that you're
supposed to be four gays
so why did they shut down basically the
gayest place on earth i mean it's all
have some water i don't i don't have any
water where's my water for god sakes
um anyway it's just it's just a whole
bunch of crazy nonsense but what i am
enthused about
is that we've got a chance to fight back
that's what the online world
is you know these people like to pretend
they're the rebel resistance and
actually they're the death star they're
the big
governmental machine that always wants
more power and wants to control how
people think
and live right what did why do they want
the death star they wanted the death
star so that every planet this is what
uh grand muff tarkin says at the
beginning of star wars they want
the death star because they know the
planets will all fall in line because if
you've got a big gun that can blow up
the planet
well then you're going to do what they
want and in many ways that is
now the goal of the left that they want
the government to do
everything the government's evil and
also give it more money and give it more
power like that's what they were doing
with the death star so that the planets
in this case the states or individual
people can't make decisions for
themselves because that thing will be so
powerful
um i'll say one other thing about about
this and when i said that joe biden
keeps turning to the camera and talking
to you like that i was
thinking i meant to mention it yesterday
i was thinking as i was watching the
debate like
i don't want a politician that says he
can solve all of my problems if trump
was telling me i could
he could solve all my problems or biden
or anyone else it's like that
line that way of thinking that
politicians or the government
can solve all of your problems they
can't solve all of my problems i
actually can't imagine a problem that i
could have
uh well i cannot i can't imagine if if
my house was on fire
then i would want the fire department to
do something and i do think that's a
role for the government
or if uh someone was attacking me on the
street that is role for the police and
that's the government but there's very
few things where you're like oh i wish
the government was here
you know like no they're not very good
at things and and that's okay by the way
and that's
that's actually what our founders were
warning us again so this thing about the
government's going to do all the things
the government's going to save you from
the environment in 12 years
the government is going to demand that
you drive an electric car
the government is going to do all these
things no
it's not going to be i'd also like to
condemn
all of the people and disavow all of the
people that think the government can do
everything because
it just can't all right i think you i
think you got the point on that one
people
uh let's move on to the second story
this is just
well it's just an extension of
everything like we're just living in
this time
of what ben shapiro talks about in in
his new book
uh we're living in a time of
disintegration like
all of the norms seem to be crumbling
and and
for if you're looking at it through the
lens of an election well then
do you think that biden is going to
accelerate
or slow down or reverse the
disintegration or
do you think the trump's going to do
that and i think i think most people
think well trump's trying to at least
restore something
and and buy it and whatever it is so
speaking of disintegration
the new ap style book guidelines
are now recommending that
journalists journalists
use the word unrest
instead of riot because riot is too
politically charged so the ap style book
for those of you that don't know
this is a book that the ap puts out i
think basically every year they update
it with a few things i have one around
here somewhere i think we've got one in
my
in my uh draw over there and basically
they tell you that the types of
in effect how you should go about being
a good journalist and a good writer and
where you should put commas and
parentheses and all of these things
okay so it's a guide for how to do basic
journalism
uh basic writing you can think about it
that way okay um
on a lot of the stuff is stuff you learn
in seventh grade but then you know
there's some deeper stuff in that
obviously
uh but now they're recommending that we
use the word unrest instead of riot and
they put out a
twitter thread and let's throw to it
i'll read it to you
uh this is uh the new guidance on ap
style book online
use care in deciding which term best
applies
a riot is a wild or violent disturbance
of the piece involving a group of
people the term riot suggests
uncontrolled chaos and pandemonium
i'll editorialize for just a moment
there that does kind of sound like what
we've seen in kenosha and what we've
seen in portland or what we've seen in
seattle
and what we've seen in new york and what
we've seen in los angeles and what we've
seen pretty much everywhere
and why is that because it is as they
say uncontrolled chaos and pandemonium
when you see milestone cocktails being
thrown at police officers and people
being hit over the head
and you know assaulting people that are
trying to sit at restaurants that sounds
like uncontrolled chaos to me
and also pandemonium the tweet thread
goes on
focusing on rioting and property
destruction rather than
underlying grievance has been used in
the past to stigmatize broad swaths of
people protesting against lynching
police brutality or for racial justice
going back to the urban uprisings of the
1960s
unrest is a vaguer milder and less
emotional term for a condition of angry
discontent
and protest verging on revolt so we'll
go back to camera for a sec you see what
they did there they went they started
going from
we use words because words have of
actual definition in fact to now
but there's a feeling we have about why
people do certain things so now we have
to change words that's very very
dangerous
the twitter thread goes on protest and
demonstration refer to specific
actions such as march-ins sit-ins
rallies or other actions meant
to register dissent they can be legal or
illegal
organized or spontaneous peaceful or
violent
and involve any number of people so what
they just said there that's a lot of
double speak right there
protest and demonstration can be
peaceful
or violent well protest
can be peaceful demonstration can be
peaceful but once it's
violent that would be what you call a
riot
i don't mean to be a stickler for the
english language but
you know come with me on this adventure
and then finally revolt
and uprising both suggest a broader
political dimension or civil upheavals a
sustained period of protest
or unrest against powerful groups or
governing
system well that seems like what we've
got now and they're doing it with riots
now i mentioned this story because on
at some level you're probably listening
to me and you're going well what
difference does it make what the ap
style book says now as i always use
quotes when i talk about journalists
um i think probably the rest of you
understand why this is important
first off there's almost no journalistic
standards anymore so this book is trying
to give some journalistic standards
they should also try giving some
journalistic standards related to
anonymous sources but that's
a whole other story um what you're
seeing here though
is that when they're trying to change
the language
they're trying to confuse our ability to
have a common conversation
once when one person sees a city burning
down and molotov cocktails and windows
being broken and people being attacked
and random people being shot
and and insurgent antifa groups creating
their own set of laws in chop in in
seattle
uh the average person would say that is
violent that is a riot
that is uh untenable for a civil society
but they would rather you call it unrest
because somehow beneath
the exterior of the violence beneath it
is good people these are good people and
they're fighting for good things so we
don't want to say they're rioters
it's just unrest and this is a
manipulation so that
so that people will watch the same thing
and depending on what your political
affiliation is or where your political
leanings are you won't be able to have a
conversation with someone because you're
going to say you're going to watch and
go that was a riot and they're going to
go no it's just unrest and then you're
going to fight each other out and it'll
most likely end in a riot
this is a problem this is a real problem
okay and i don't know if you've ever
heard of this but there was a book by a
guy named george orwell
it was written about gosh probably about
70 years ago
something like that around 1950 maybe um
and george orwell in 1984 many of you of
course know in 1984
one of the things he talked about was
newspeak okay and i wanna i wanna
actually read to you what newspeak is
in this dystopian society that he
believed would occur in 1984 maybe it
took a little bit longer than george
orwell thought but newspeak
this is the wikipedia definition of
newspeak although wikipedia has got a
little news speak in and of itself
the political purpose of newspeak is to
eliminate the expression of the shades
of meaning inherent to ambiguity and
nuance
from old speak standard english in order
to reduce the language's function of
communication by way of simplistic
concepts of simple construction pleasure
verse pain happiness verse sadness good
think verse crime think
the last one of these which
linguistically reinforces the state's
dominance of the people of oceania so
that's that that's the
uh where they live is oceana that's the
country that they live in
um if you haven't seen 1984 i mean
there's a movie
hopefully you've read it but if you
haven't done either one of those and you
don't have much time
uh i did a video with michael knowles uh
for the prageru book club
where we dissect 1984 and in effect we
end up just talking about current events
because there are so many phrases
from 1984 and so much of the landscape
politically
that george orwell talks about is
happening now
this is it what once was science fiction
is now reality words are changing in
front of us and what they're also doing
is these are the same people who will
say violence
is not violent meaning if you burn down
a building that's not violence because
you there's insurance and no human
no person was hurt directly right so
that's not violence but they'll also
tell you
that words are violent so that if you
misgender someone
that's violence yet if they call someone
else a nazi that doesn't count as that
kind of word violence
none of it makes sense and none of it
makes sense by design
and and i think the more you understand
that the more you can make sense of the
world
and actually that does bring me to an
interesting point which is i was on
twitter this morning
and i was thinking you know and i
tweeted something out about this
it seemed crazier than usual like things
do seem crazier than usual and it's it's
partly because of what i just talked
about where
we're all seeing different versions of
reality and as i've been saying there's
a war
on reality that's what's happening right
now um but the people
that are making sense to me right now
are the people
that are honestly looking at the world
as it is not as they want it to be but
if you only look at the world as you
want it to be you will be endlessly
miserable because guess what you don't
own the world buddy
you can work to make it better but you
don't own it uh speaking of working to
make it better i got one other story
that i'm gonna do relatively quickly
uh coinbase ceo his name is brian
armstrong
uh he issued an interesting statement uh
and it's got a lot of people pissed off
and then the
the former ceo of twitter got involved
i'll get to that in a second but he just
poured gasoline on the whole thing
so brian armstrong said that basically
he wanted to get
in effect what he wants to do is get
social justice out of his company
i don't know where he stands politically
but he understands that once you let
these ideas in
and then everyone's fighting about
everything that you're going to go
off mission right and i've talked about
this a bunch and peter bogosian who's a
friend who i've had on the show many
times he talks about this
if you let social justice into an
organization whether you think it's good
or bad or indifferent
once you have people focusing on how
many black people should we have and how
many asian people should we have and how
many gay people should we have
you've already directed resources away
from the goal which should be to make a
better product or sell more stuff or
whatever it is
you know have a better hotel whatever
business you're in you've directed
resources to things that are
in many ways uh contrary to what the
original business motivation is okay so
uh so in effect ceo
brian armstrong this is what he said he
said while i think these efforts talking
about social justice
are well-intentioned they have the
potential to destroy a lot of value at
most
companies both by being a distraction
and creating internal division
now that is true there's no doubt that
that's true it's true for the reasons
that i just said it's true because then
everyone is hung up in human resources
fights
you're going to have if you're hiring
people based on immutable
characteristics you're not going to hire
the people who are most qualified we
used to call that
racism if you hire people based on the
color of their skin you know i'm old
school
so this creates a whole series of
problems and he's just
in effect the ceo of coinbase is
basically just saying hey
i you know we do bitcoin we're in
exchange for for crypto
that's what we want to focus on we don't
want to focus on all this other stuff
and as the ceo of the company he has the
right to do that
i'm i'm the uh ceo of well technically i
guess i'm the ceo
of uh david my partner my husband
is the ceo of our production company but
we make the decisions and
we that's what your right to do is if
you own a business you have the right to
create the culture that you want well
then former
twitter ceo dick costello
responded about this and and this is
just a doozy he said
me first capitalists who think you can
separate society from business are going
to be the first people lined up against
the wall
and shot in the revolution i'll happily
provide video commentary
he is partly right here that yes they
will go for capitalists
they'll get you of course uh dick
costello you're not gonna believe how
much
dick is worth okay dick's got a lot of
dough
dick is worth 300 million dollars dick
has done quite well
uh in our capitalist society i don't
know what level
of social justice or or money he gives
to organizations or any of that stuff
but what he's doing there
is this if you're if you're curious
we're defining a lot of things today if
you're curious what's
what virtue signaling is this is virtue
signaling at its height
this is a man who through capitalism and
through creating twitter which might
ultimately be the
the most evil thing in the history of
human society uh
created tremendous amount of wealth as i
just said he's worth 300 million dollars
now what he's trying to do is say ah but
i see the barbarians are at the gates
i see you guys are coming you guys are
about to burn the whole thing down
hey can i film it can i film it can i
film it so you'll spare me
and that is virtue signaling you have no
virtue that you're gonna film
as they bring your friends and former
co-workers
to the guillotine man that is cowardice
of epic proportions
lordy lordy lordy all right
uh that is the reuben report direct
message
for today uh i'll be back on tuesday
with more
uh want to remind you guys that uh
yesterday we did the
uh i hosted it here on the reuben report
channel we did about a two and a half
hour gathering it was the freedom fest
emergency session and i along with mark
skousen who
is the uh founder of freedom fest uh we
interviewed about 20 people
a couple of the people you'll you'll
recognize from the reuben report
including michael malus
and matt kibby and a couple others uh
and it was a
wide-ranging talk all sort of focused on
freedom and liberty but we talked about
it from a political angle from a covet
angle
from a big tech angle whole bunch of
stuff and i think you'll find it really
interesting you can just kind of jump in
and out and skip around but the
conversations were
were pretty enlightening and uh and the
reason that we did it online by the way
is because we were supposed to do it
in las vegas in august the event was
canceled i was really looking forward to
it i haven't left
la once since this stupid lockdown began
and uh and i said to them
basically i was like look guys i would
love to host this on my channel so we
can get these ideas and
and voices out there and all that stuff
uh anyway
uh have a good rest of your thursday
everyone enjoy your
friday and your saturday and your sunday
and monday's all right too
and i'll be back on tuesday and we've
got some more interviews coming up joe
jorgensen the libertarian presidential
candidate i believe that's what we're
putting up next
and uh that's all i've got i will
continue my list
of people to condemn because i feel like
i left off some
people but but for sure i'm not i'm not
condemning the uh
well i was going to say the autobots but
you know
they're not perfect either all right see
ya